what have you heard about the amber
heard case have you guys heard anything
about it
i've only seen the live on tick tock
when he was given his testimony and
stuff like that that's about it
um so basically amber and johnny depp
were dating they were together okay
and um
amber came out a couple years ago and
had an article saying that she was in a
relationship that was abusive
and everybody in hollywood knew that it
was about him
and
so
basically he was blacklisted from
hollywood remember like when we were
younger he was in pirates of the
caribbean and like all these movies they
just the best movies yeah yeah and she
didn't take him to court over this like
there was nothing legally that happened
but everyone just believed her because
you know the the phrases kind of believe
all women right
they take that this man's career is
ruined and now a couple years later he's
coming back and suing her
because it turns out he was actually the
one being abused
so um and this includes
um she threw a bottle at him and his
finger was severed
um she
there were accounts of him like hitting
her or her hitting him
and
just different accounts of like her
being very abusive towards him
so um it sort of begs the question
should we cancel somebody before all the
facts have come out and should we just
believe women when they accuse somebody
of assault or
abuse the situation seems a bit toxic
you know back and forth but
yeah i think definitely not you need to
know like what's going on because
like i said
people are more likely to believe the
woman
there's both sin they're abusing each
other and they're more likely to believe
the woman so just by cancelling the man
yeah straight up as well without any
facts
yeah with no basis yeah you always i
feel like you should get like both sides
of the story not just the woman's side
obviously it favors the woman in every
type of way you're like going against
the man and stuff but it's always better
to find
both sides of the story that's why i
think i think with like this generation
on the counseling part we're so quick to
cancel everyone
and i think that comes
um very much from our own insecurities
of always wanting to cancel people
um which is just very sad we don't know
all the facts and we still just decide
to cancel people like that
i agree i very strongly agree
um so why do you guys think
it's so common for if a girl comes
forward to just cancel the guy whether
or not the facts have come out
why do you think that is because it
doesn't seem like it's the other way
around it seems like it only happens
some women do it for their benefit i
guess like that would be
like money or something like that
because it's easy because it's easy for
example like if you're
uh if you like if a man makes a certain
amount of money and he's like let's say
famous and stuff like that and a woman
just
she doesn't know the man but she can
make up a real enough story to where the
judge can believe it
she can extort him for some amount of
money before the truth can come out if
she's got all her facts straight and
stuff like that with the with the
correct backstory so some people do like
that for like money and stuff like that
i think what was the question like why
do you think that is as a society why do
we just believe women
i think um
i think typically
women i think typically women are um
more preyed on by men
um or at least in a woman's lifetime
and they would have experienced
harassment in comparison to men so it's
easier for people to believe a woman
whenever she whenever she
makes these claims because
just generally speaking
at least in my personal experience
majority if not 100 of the women i've
women i know have at least at some point
in their lifetime experience harassment
by males whereas none of the men i know
have experienced it which is why i
believe it's easier
to um to believe a woman without the
facts even though it's not right to do
so
yeah
what do you guys think i mean like
it's like judging a book by its title
really you haven't read the whole story
to really understand what's going on so
just going off the back i feel like
maybe we need to actually
learn to assess things properly before
we jump to conclusions because you never
know that woman generally could be lying
on someone's name for her own benefit so
yeah it is a bit it was a bit toxic that
that situation so i'm just curious to
the girls have you ever had a girl that
you know tell you that she'd been
assaulted
oh yeah 100
100 yeah dude do you question it or do
you automatically believe her i never
question the victim i try to not but i
will ask questions
if she's comfortable answering those
questions um
but i think it's important to at least
start off by believing the victim
because they need to be comfortable
enough to tell you yeah and there's a
lot of like emotion attached to it as
well it's not just like them you know
telling the story there's a lot of like
ptsd emotion and things that are going
with it
yeah i've had to fight a person once
but yeah but i've i seen that thing
happen like i seen that yeah yeah yeah
it was um it was one of my friends and
stuff like i shot a
guy over i guess and
yeah one thing led to another he was a
bit there i heard something that i
shouldn't have heard i walked in and
this guy's doing my masalini's next to
you know i busted his head through the
window so
yeah
um sure you guys bring the mic to your
mouth if you're gonna talk just there's
some comments about it um what do you
think
so it's interesting though because we
say like
we can't just believe all women but we
kind of do as girls
you know like if a girl comes to you and
says something like that that's kind of
our immediate gut reaction
and it's tough because i feel like
celebrity situations kind of model real
life you know what i mean like like
they're kind of examples of what's going
on in like our real lives but like when
it hits the forefront that's when you
have an example of it
i think
i think that's because as women
we've experienced similar things so it's
hard not to believe someone coming out
and saying these things because it's
unfortunately so common
so yeah so me being um a victim of
domestic abuse um
i feel like for me to tell someone was
very hard i wouldn't tell anybody so if
somebody comes up to you and actually
talks about it then i would actually
believe them because it's not just like
yeah a topic you just you know tell
anyone yeah so yeah
um
on
the question that you asked i think
why you would um
believe the woman first is because
obviously if you see a man
saying that he's getting beat up by his
girlfriend that's
it's
it happens but it's rare like
men are seen as stronger than women
so it's like
when a man's
saying he's getting abused by his
girlfriend or and the girlfriend saying
you're more likely to believe the girl
because
men are seen to be bigger stronger it's
like it's
unlikely that a girl is gonna beat up
their boyfriend but it does happen so
yeah that's why i think yeah women
you know what's interesting i've heard
more men tell me like in person my
personal life that they've been victims
of domestic assault than women
yeah like because a lot of guys don't
report it because they don't feel
comfortable because you're getting beat
up by a girl
so is that also like another problem
like you know i'm fine takes a whole new
meaning for the guy you know what i mean
because when a girl says i'm fine like
you gotta go and you gotta make sure
that she's really fine because she's
never fine but like when when a guy says
it's like he's holding a different
meaning
yeah like she was just saying it was
hard for like you to come out and speak
about it
i think as a man it may be even be
harder because
um
like
people could laugh at you like if you're
a woman you get bit more sympathy i
think but if your mind is gonna be even
harder like
if you're going through that sort of
thing yeah you have to be quite quite
strong and brazilian yeah yeah it's
going to happen because because
generally speaking like if a man comes
out saying oh my wife be always like
most guys responses and even some of the
females are listening stop being a [ __ ]
like why why you being a [ __ ] you know
what i mean
yeah like you know what i mean like yo
yo you're the man of the house why are
you not why are you not telling her what
you know i mean it's just that's
it
even in the audio tape with um amber and
johnny depp where he secretly recorded
her confessing to
assaulting him she was calling him a
[ __ ] yeah you know
yeah yeah yeah i mean that's a lot of
respect as well 100 for your
relationship to get into that kind of
stage where
a lot is going on like that so
do you think that if a girl hits a guy
he can hit her back
i don't think so i don't think equality
i had last time last i checked human
wanted equality so that's a very mm-hmm
i mean like
i mean
you could like pin her down
yeah don't try it you can't you know
what i mean but there's other ways
around it you don't need to now give her
a black eye or something because yeah i
feel like you can do other i feel like
things i feel like um
a man shouldn't
just because of the the the potential
damage it could cause you know and he
could then go into a rage but he should
he should like he said putting her down
or you know stand grounds you know what
i mean yeah not to just take because
devil's advocate what happened to that
guy in miami when he didn't hit her back
the guy in miami with the only fans
model
oh the one has to go stop he died right
right because she stabbed him
what
i got did you not hear about that no
he's
and you know what's interesting in court
like um
men get four times the sentencing for
the same crime
oh wow yeah than women
so it's like even if they do get
convicted like girls aren't really sent
to jail over this stuff it's really not
taken like the same yeah why do you guys
think that is
i think similar to what i said earlier
like they get more sympathy because
they're seen as more
fragile fragile yeah like feminine you
know girls girls aren't seen as like
people who yeah like
men can be seen as evil aggressive like
but then when women are doing the same
thing
it's
you it's unexpected so like it's not as
believable when it does happen
that's crazy i was gonna say so like you
said that obviously like if a woman hits
a man you really shouldn't like you know
him but like where would you just draw
the line because for example like
hitting is one thing yeah but like if
you see a woman like like you said like
the man that died right it's a woman's
coming at you with a knife would you
feel like that's a
valuable reason for you to actually take
but that's nice
you got a whole weapon like she's got a
whole weapon like they're you're
fighting for your life at that point
she's put you in a position where you
might have to actually knock her out
yeah
jeremy but that's a lot
it is
yeah i think that if she hits you you
should be able to hit her back because i
think that women would maybe take it a
little bit more seriously before you hit
a guy
like i just think girls like today they
have no consequence they can they can do
damn near anything there's like no
consequence but a guy he gets sent to
like jail or prison over that stuff yeah
i get what you're saying but
if a woman slaps a man and then a man
slaps a woman
the guy is more likely to be stronger
and he's going to do more damage
what are you gaining from slapping her
back like yeah but it's like she
shouldn't have been slapping him in the
first place that's what i'm saying it
does take a lot for like a woman to
actually grab that courage and slap a
man because i guess it depends on the
way it's like depends it does depend on
the woman but it also depends on the
situation as well okay
like troy said i think if you're able to
leave leave
why are you fighting back but if it's
life or death then obviously you have to
hit back believe i just think if
i put this do you okay so if it's about
strength right
do you think that a weaker if a weaker
guy hits a jacked guy
that the jack guy can't hit him back
skinny skinny that's a skinny on a
muscle man that's that's just that's
just a fight i would like to see i'm not
gonna lie like let's say let's say he's
just feeling ballsy okay and he he hits
the like the most jacked guy in the room
hey listen nominos padres to you my
brother
live long i hope you survive i promise
you yeah like i'm just
there's no it would be so funny because
like the jag guy would probably just
pick him up and throw just just flip him
just like go
no but the same way i don't think a jack
guy would would actively go into a
fight with somebody who who he sees to
be weaker than him unless he's on
steroids
yeah yeah if we're talking like if we're
talking generally a guy who knows he can
definitely
well because he has the consequence
right
but women don't have the consequences
because one the law isn't holding them
accountable
and two
the um
like guys think they can't hit them back
yeah that's true
so how do we how do we hold women
accountable then so this doesn't happen
in the future like what do you think we
could do to change things like this
that's i think that's probably why she
was
uh had more motivation or courage to do
it because she knew the
she wasn't she didn't think she would
get caught yeah she thinks are
me hitting this guy like no one's going
to believe him
yeah
that's given her more
um
you know more energy to do it yeah
whereas if i think if there was
if they make like a statement now or
they make um an example of her then
women in the future are going to be like
oh no they're going to be more scared to
like
beat up their vulnerable boyfriends or
whatever i think harsher sentences or
equals yeah i was going to say yeah it
has to be from a law yeah exactly
not even i'm really the law is corrupt
though this is yeah it is but i was
going to say i'm really happy he came
out and did it even though it's like
several years later yeah because it
shows them he he's like a role model to
so many people yeah so it shows that you
can be vulnerable you can be a man like
do you think for a girl
if a girl damages a guy's character so
if a girl goes around saying that he did
something doesn't press charges do you
think the guy
do you think she should be able to be
punished like criminally for that 100
yeah um
at least for a guy once you're accused
of something even if you found innocent
that will stick if he says the same
thing back he's they're either going to
say he's just doing it to be petty but
do you know what i mean or they're just
not going to believe it you know what
i'm trying to say yeah
yeah i feel like that she needs to be
held accountable if she does that
isn't that illegal to begin with
well she i don't think she guys correct
me in the chat if i'm wrong but i don't
think she legally like tried to
like i don't think she took him to court
over it so um i think it would be
illegal if she took him to court but she
just basically put out an article that
was very like one-sided and just said
that like it was so abusive and then he
it tarnished his career in hollywood
because especially a couple years ago it
very much was just believe all women
like remember that like it was that was
everywhere
and so you know that that just like
ruined his career
let me see if they am i right in the
chat i wanted to see
yeah so do you think um like if someone
does that on like a campus they should
be able to sue like the same thing
well like universities like spreading
rumors in camp
you know like rumors
honestly yeah because like in in high
school like we've all spread i've spread
rumors in high school when i was younger
i'm not gonna actually i'm guilty i've
we're not going to get into it yeah but
i've i've had rumor spread about me and
then you just carried on to college and
stuff like we do that type of job i
don't think it would be like
anything serious like anything that you
could take legal action upon like oh
this guy
like it's kind of like university oh
this like it's a small university that
we have in new york right and if someone
has sex with someone
it's instant because it's such a small
campus so like the rumor the word gets
around quickly but i was just like i
don't think they they should be like
legally
but i think it does exactly exactly you
know what i mean if it takes away
opportunities from you and yeah biggest
opportunities then you're you should be
that's a big roommate you're spreading
it
what would take your chances away from
you like unless it's unless like your
lecturers hear about like you doing some
crazy stuff the night before
yeah like yeah yeah
yeah yeah if it's if it's like something
along the lines of like oh this guy
yeah and her and her and her and then
all the time yeah
but if it's like involving like drugs
and your career and stuff like that
because athletes and drugs that kind of
stuff yeah all the time so it is is a
bit of what are you spreading type thing
that will have an effect on someone
have you guys ever
been in a situation where somebody
accused someone of someone and you
didn't really believe them
like it doesn't have to be a close
friend but just someone you knew yeah
yeah
well i'll see you as well what what like
what happened
um it was a friend of mine not a friend
of mine a mutual friend of mine um who
said that she was pregnant
and as a mutual friend
um
i told my friend to ask her like yo show
us the test so we can help you
she refuses to show us the test
um for weeks like six weeks eight weeks
we say we'll come to the doctors with
you he's like no i want no one there so
we show up the doctor there's no
appointment
and so after like five months we're like
was this true she's like no oh my god so
what was that like an attempt i've had
this i've heard the same thing but that
was an attention move but
the fact that we had to still feel sorry
for her because to go to that length
to do that
it takes a lot
so yeah
yeah wait you still felt sorry for her i
i feel sorry for her because you have to
be at a very low point in your life to
say first of all accuse this boy of
making you pregnant because he's on the
other side like show me the test as a
father he should be able to see the test
i just think you're like a bad person
you are but you feel sorry for someone i
don't feel sorry for that
so what would you you're just such a
nice person you're such a nice person
man
i was like
i mean
like if i came to you and i was like oh
my gosh i'm pregnant
what would your first initial like
reaction be how far along are you
i would say
well
when did it happen my first initial
reaction to people i know is to believe
them i don't i don't naturally just
think people are crazy
yeah you know then it's like you would
ha you have to kind of but poke at that
person to kind of know
yeah yeah i mean it's it's more like
you don't always know the character of
people so you ask like questions right
how far along are you who's the dad and
if everything like lines up you kind of
yeah you naturally believe people
but
that's not something to really lie about
being pregnant why would you lie about
that especially when you tell the person
that you think is the father of the baby
because that puts him in a very
vulnerable position i can ruin a man as
well exactly because then he's got to
tell his his family
like all of this like
and then if it's not even true then you
you've had all that stress for no reason
literally
do you think that
men should be able to take a woman to
court for that
for lying absolutely pregnant absolutely
yeah
no
look at it this way right
she just told me that she's pregnant
right cool so now i've got to go and
like you said tell you tell my family
and then they're gonna have a go at me
and then their family gonna go and
they're gonna want it and you know how
like some old old uh old testament
family is like oh i wanna see a test i
wanna see this i wanna meet the girls
parents and stuff like that and then you
go through all that length through all
that trouble to ideally
basically ruin the man's life
and then all of that just to find out
that she's not really pregnant
absolutely that's it yeah absolutely you
should be able to take it to court
yeah i mean it does play a big role
that's a whole lot you gotta you gotta
look at it like this right let's say you
let's say for example you say you're
pregnant to me and i and i'm the dad
right yeah cool i go away and i do
whatever i gotta do now i dropped out of
university because right now i've got
work and supplies now i've got a job you
know what i mean and then you come and
find out that um you know you know what
i mean about life stuff like that no way
it's big it's too much of a big impact
to carry that into someone else's life
not just your own that is
big
yeah do you what about if a girl had to
go to like do you think she should be
able to go to jail for that
i think i mean much
he gets like mad depressed he ends up
like killing himself and stuff because
because you made some mad rumor like
emotional damage yeah
then she should be held accountable
because you've like you basically killed
in time
i mean yeah
how much i think that this might be
consequences they can't just be back you
can't be on a case by case based make up
a wild rumor and like ruin someone's
life what if
he commits suicide after her just sent
like texting and saying i'm praying this
your baby she should still go to jail
jail for one message no no okay see this
is the difference
i just think there has to be some level
of accountability because i just think
the way i look at society is like
if you take away the consequences for
anything there are shitty people that
are going to abuse it and i just think
these days
we've taken away a lot of the
consequence for women with stuff like
believe all women with stuff like
even like the in court you know and even
just our society naturally empathizing
with women and you know taking them at
face value yeah but i feel like you
can't do that too much because then
you're putting rules and laws on every
single little thing like there'll be a
lot there'll be a law firm for
everything like you can't say this you
can't do that and then people be
restricted yeah then you've got no
freedom i'm not i'm not talking about
that i'm talking about just i'm just
talking about women getting equal
sentencing for the same crime
yeah or i'm talking about like even in
this conversation
what most people didn't agree with me
when i said you should be able to hit a
woman back
i i didn't i refused to answer that
because no comment is the best comment
you know i'm saying yeah i would smack a
[ __ ] if she got knife yo
that then it's different but i think
like troy if she slaps you then why
would you slap her back like pin her
down let her know you're the man yeah
just restrict them
before she hits me
no you can't try again do you know what
i mean there's not a thing where you
need to now go we had damagers
we had a talk about a similar thing what
was it of course to go when we talked
about like oh you shouldn't be able to
like you shouldn't have to hit a woman
yet but you you need to go to as a man
you need to go to a certain length here
to where she needs to understand that no
matter how strong she thinks she is she
will get put down and you know i mean
like
yeah so if you're not gonna hit if
you're not gonna hit the woman back even
if you grab her wrist and
or like or if you're gonna stay yeah you
know what i mean
i don't know
to hit a woman i mean you're going to do
some damage or at least if i if i'm if
i'm if it's me
and if i respond
yeah but you know what it is yeah some
some women right
this normally happens
in like a fresh relationship right it's
like when a woman starts smiling out and
starts like going on to like try to
abuse the man like him or whatever right
and the guy obviously doesn't do
anything but like let her know that
she's not gonna do it and then she goes
like oh my god she hit me he done this
he's done that and she will go through
some women will be crazy enough to
actually hit themselves making it look
like the man done it and then report it
to the law yeah but maybe there's maybe
she's going through her own like
emotional why take it out on the guy
though
yeah maybe there's an issue there
not just like her
towards a guy maybe okay but would you
say that if the roles were reversed
if a dude did that to a woman if if a
dude
and it's just it's just funny because
that's our and i think it's like natural
in us yeah like like when a guy does
something it's just not as empathized
but the women when women a woman does
something it's like well what about her
mental state what about what she was
going through